I think I was an engineer and a
scientist from day one I was very
surprised and overwhelmed terrified
happy thrilled bouncing off the walls I
was in a hotel room so I could bounce
off the walls and nobody would see me I
was walking around in circles because I
wasn't allowed to call home and then
after I called home I could I was
walking around in circles because no one
answered the telephone it was a pretty
thrilling moment then I really had to
take a shower because I knew it would be
a very long day
[Music]
it's a bit of a funny story my first
phone call was to my son James I and of
course he didn't answer the phone until
a couple hours later and his reaction
was when he answered the phone was what
do you want mom it was five o'clock in
the morning and he was tired and so I
said James I won the Nobel Prize and I
can't repeat exactly what he said here
but he said oh my goodness that was just
he was so thrilled for me and of course
he jumped in the car drove over to
another house where my other son was
sound of sleep and woke him up and then
the two of them came to meet me at
Caltech later that day so when I finally
got back to Caltech because all the
flights were full from Dallas to Los
Angeles so I made it back about Oh
ten hours after the announcement
I made it back and Caltech picked me up
at the airport and brought me to campus
and all my students were spread out on
the campus they had made big posters
they were wearing their lab t-shirts and
they gave me a standing ovation as I
walked onto campus it was really lovely
and then all my colleagues congregated
in the Chairman's office and toasted me
with champagne
[Music]
I'm still working on that one it's a
fairly recent event and up till today
winning the Nobel Prize has meant a lot
of work putting together schedules and
hearing from many friends and supporters
hearing from my old babysitter's I have
heard from thousands of people all over
the world many of whom I've never met
who just want to say how happy they are
for me I've heard from many people I
have met and have long forgotten but
I've heard from many people who I care
about so it seems to be a shared event
it's not just about me it's about
everyone you've ever touched in your
whole life and people you haven't yet
touched but now will as a result of this
prize
my father was a physicist
experimentalist and he loved fixing
things and building things he would
allow us in the workshop every once in a
while I had four brothers so we were
always competing who would be better in
math who would be better at building
things I I always had a flair for
competition
[Music]
well for one thing as I was growing up I
was shaped by the fact that I had all
these brothers some older one is older
three were younger so I learned how to
hold my own with the bigger boy but also
how to boss everybody else around and so
I ended up organizing the brothers a lot
but we're also very close in fact three
of my brothers are here with me in
Stockholm and we had friendly
competitions for many things no there
wasn't
of course as I was growing up being a
scientist was not on my list of things
to do I enjoyed science I wanted to be a
scientist when I was a kid I didn't
worry about too much what I would do and
I would I was going to grow up but I
tried lots of different things I thought
I would be a diplomat then I realized I
had no diplomatic skills I wanted to be
a CEO of a multinational corporation
then I realized that was a lot of work
and I studied engineering because it was
the easiest option and the easiest way
to get into Princeton University at that
time and I never left
I love solving problems I think science
and engineering is a fabulous career for
people who see problems in the world
that need solutions my talent happens to
be in coming up with technological
solutions to those problems but there
are plenty of problems for which we will
need solutions so I think that's a
lovely way to use your skills and
creativity in in identifying problems
and then finding clever new ways to
solve them
the traits that are important to be
successful in science include an ability
to accept criticism there's plenty of it
to go around and to benefit from
criticism if someone takes enough time
to criticize your work in a constructive
way and you are able to listen to that
of course you know you have to put set
aside the feelings of hurt feelings say
perhaps that what I need to listen to
what's going on why is this idea not
coming across what is the fault I have
in the way I communicate the idea or
maybe the idea really is lousy but we
have to be able to join the discussion
[Music]
as a scientist and and engineer
independence of course is extremely
important you have to come up with your
own solutions to problems you have to
come up with your own questions if
you're going to be a scientist and
really explore something new on the
other hand teamwork is important so this
wonderful balance of independent
creativity but then convincing all these
dozens of students to take on some of
these problems and and put their own
ideas into it is is this is the balance
that we have to master I don't think
it's necessary that scientists work on
problems of societal impact there's so
many wonderful stories of how just
curiosity has led to societal impact and
that if you start off saying I'm going
to solve climate change huge problems or
figure out how to purify water you may
come up with a solution or you may not
it may not be a particular person's
passion I think science is beautiful and
that those of us who have a passion to
understand how the universe works how
communities work how people work how our
minds work just to understand that will
also contribute to eventually solving
the problems
[Music]
I particularly like working on
problem-solving that comes from probably
my personality but also my engineering
background engineering is all about how
do you come up with a solution to a
problem but I should say that much of my
work has deep science roots where if we
come up with a solution for a problem
what does that tell us about the
underlying phenomenon what do we learn
and evolution such a great way to do
this I use this process of evolution to
create new biological things that no one
would know how to design they're too
complicated but once I have them and I
solves a problem I can go in and do the
reverse engineering
I can understand or try to understand
how they acquired the new traits that
they have and that way I can contribute
to a more fundamental understanding of
how by a lot biology works and how
evolution works
I have done a lot of thinking over the
last few months about the scientists and
philosophers and writers who've
influenced my work for the last 40 years
I've been strongly influenced by Jorge
Luis Borges a writer by the philosopher
Dan Dennett and by a whole slew of
really creative scientists who whose
ideas I recombined in some new way and
it's wonderful to go back and view those
ideas and see in retrospect how they
were reassembled
[Music]
the diversity of background that I have
which runs the gamut from studying
Russian literature to aerospace
engineering and chemical engineering and
I speak a number of languages I've been
interested in many things over my
lifetime I didn't actually become a
professor of chemical engineering until
I was thirty years old I was doing many
other things before that including being
a taxi driver all those experiences even
if they were not the most positive
experiences made my made me who I am and
I think the diversity of experience is
makes me very different from everybody
else
[Music]
I try not to give too much advice
because specific advice doesn't help my
path is different from your path but
don't be afraid of a path take it when
you come to the fork in the road take it
do something right even if you don't
know what it is and where it will lead
you do it do something and do it as well
as you can if you don't like it take
another path life is not doors closing
it should be doors opening
I think it's neither too early nor too
late to become a scientist or engineer
it may be hard to study that math but
you could do lots of interesting things
just by being curious
I work in a remarkable institution the
California Institute of Technology we
have 900 undergraduates and a thousand
graduate students it's really small and
they come from all over the world just
in love with science and that's what
they want to do they want to do science
and they want to do it at the highest
levels so I am working with these
tremendously talented and motivated
people their ideas are phenomenal they
haven't been molded into some you know a
hard set piece of clay they're
completely open and their creativity is
just waiting to be unleashed so I get to
spark that flame and watch that
creativity just explode how could you
not like that it's very much privileged
to work with them they're nice people
they care about others it's my job to
provide them the resources to do science
the environment that lets them feel free
to express this creativity the support
they need when it fails as it inevitably
does everybody goes through periods of
oh nothing works and then to give them
the credit also when everything works
and they graduate and go on to form
their careers
I have 250 children as a result of this
over the years many of whom are coming
to Stockholm and the ones who aren't
have all you know participated in some
way in this event
it's all about the people I'm one brain
and sometimes there's one brain that can
do everything but that's not my brain
but what I'm good at is encouraging 20
brains to work together and when you
have 20 really good brains you can do a
lot so I like to to bring those brains
together we enjoy each other we're
friends and we like to celebrate our
successes so I have a group of many of
those people who've gone on to other
careers who are coming back to celebrate
this
I had several mentors as a younger
scientist people whose work I admired
whose ideas I admired and who encouraged
me to go and try wonderful things people
who found me a job in Brazil in the
1970s and people who supported my PhD
aspirations throughout my career I've
been lucky to have inspirational
scientists
I think it's enjoyable to inspire the
next generation of scientists I I try to
avoid the moniker role model because
there are many things I've done that I
certainly would not want to model for
anyone life is challenging and we all
have to go through ups and downs but I
would love in any way if I can inspire
people to keep going through the hard
parts science is not easy this is a hard
job and you have to be willing to take
that criticism and you have to be
willing to take those failures but the
joy is far outweigh the difficulties in
my mind well I keep going because if I
don't solve this problem I'll go to
another problem right I I loved
problem-solving but I haven't chosen any
one specific problem I define my
problems and if you define your problems
maybe you can even come up with problems
people didn't even know where problems
and then when you solve it it they
realized that was hey that was a really
interesting problem so that's that's one
way to get around the problem of failure
[Music]
I think we're doing we're starting to do
that what I'm finding is that in my
field in chemistry there are a lot of
really bright strong women doing
chemistry and they're doing great
chemistry it's a challenge of course to
juggle everything of course I think
women are the best jugglers I don't know
anybody who juggles were things and
women do but we also take on a lot to
juggle so these are the challenges has
had to encourage women to take on yet
more balls in the air and say you can do
this and you can actually enjoy it as
well
[Music]
I'm sure there are many challenges that
that I've encountered I have to say my
personality is that I'm blissfully
unaware if someone doesn't like what I
do I've always been able to say well
sorry that's who I am and that's what I
like to do I think that having the four
brothers helped there so many of the
challenges where people would look at my
work and for example disregard its
importance or say it's not science which
is criticism I had early on I could just
say well I'm going to do it anyway I
think the progress of women taking on
careers at universities and science and
technology the progress has been slow
but it has been somewhat study it it's
still not good enough I don't see the
50% parity that I see it under graduate
level for example at Caltech 50% of the
undergraduates are women but only 20% of
the professor's to some extent that's a
time difference and maybe in ten years
that will change but I'm not sure that's
the case there's something systemic that
is holding women back from wanting to do
this job I think if they want to do the
job they couldn't do it and they could
get the jobs but for some reason a
number of them say early on well I don't
want to be like you I don't want to work
as hard as you do I don't want to have
all these responsibilities because I'd
like to focus elsewhere it's not easy to
do everything
[Music]
it is something that the system can help
with and and many improvements have been
made when I had a baby in 1990 my
university had no maternity policy
because no one had had a baby before so
that had to be developed and now
everybody has babies but that was a new
phenomenon and we had to go through the
process of how do we support women so
that they can succeed and can have all
the other things that everyone wants my
favorite advice for young women who want
to do science and engineering is by all
means do it even if you don't want to do
it don't leave it for the men because
it's so much fun it's fun it's important
it's really thrilling to use your
creativity to do useful things for
people don't leave it for the men
[Music]
I think everybody needs to know
something about science and engineering
maybe they don't go and get a degree in
it but we need a scientifically literate
population sciences and technology it's
a future it's a future of the planet
without science and technology we won't
feed 10 billion people we won't provide
water or we won't have cities that are
even worth living in
it's science and technology so everybody
has to do it and most certainly women
are going to play a huge role in the
future of science and technology because
that's where a 50% of the best minds are
the wonderful thing about evolution is
that here is a design process that works
at all scales from molecules to
ecosystems one design algorithm that
solved everything in life created
everything in the living world what I
realized is that we're just at the
beginning of using evolution to move
into the future so what that means is
that these processes that we pioneered
many years ago have started to be used
by hundreds of people thousands of
people to do very creative things with
real applications so for example
pharmaceuticals are being manufactured
using enzymes that have been optimized
by directed evolution that's important
because they used to be made using toxic
metals and processes that would generate
tons literally tons of waste products
now they're made using a clean enzyme
process I brought here it's one of my
guests to Stockholm a young man who
started a company he got his PhD in my
lab doing directed evolution and he
recently started a company that's
replacing pesticides with insect
pheromones turns out if you spray a
little bit of a insect pheromone in a
field you can confuse males when you
confuse the male insects they don't mate
no caterpillars the crop damage is not
there and it's a wonderful organic
replacement for dumping pesticides onto
the planet all made by synthetic biology
by engineering biological systems to
make chemicals that they don't normally
make and these applications are
thrilling to me because I see a
sustainable future for the planet by
using some of these design processes and
designed molecules that nature invented
I started my career back in the 1970s
working on solar energy when President
Carter was our leader and the United
States had a national goal of 20%
renewable energy by the year 2000 it was
a shame that that national goal of
course went by the wayside when there
was a change of administration and I
felt that my career path in solar energy
might be somewhat limited so I switched
out of solar energy and went into
biotechnology at the beginning of the
DNA revolution I stayed with renewable
energy though looking at ways we could
replace pumping oil out of the ground
and using biological systems then and
I've stayed with that ever that that
passion for replacing dirty chemical
processes with clean biological
processes for many years because I care
deeply about our natural world and how
we can maintain a beautiful natural
world all these interesting products of
evolution lions and tigers and rhinos
and monkeys and even insects these
things are beautiful they're beautiful
products of evolution and we will be
greatly impoverished if we do not make
space for all these other things that we
admire